Garth Brooks is opening up like never
before there's two part documentary
special Garth Brooks the road I'm on so
fans will see another side the two-time
artist of the decade recipient behind
the scenes look into his personal life a
phenom will rise to superstardom I'm
Garth Brooks and this is my story it's
like when I watch The Beatles on The Ed
Sullivan Show we are living our dream
and we're not letting go
we are the luckiest guys
but history's in the past do not ever
think what we've done is good enough
speaking with Us Weekly before its
premiere an Amy Garza opened up above
being completely unfiltered and allowing
his entire family to be part of the dock
including his ex-wife Sandi Mahl
revealing what really surprised me was
sandy the girl's mom she was phenomenal
imagine you're gonna get divorced you
lose your mama
try swallowing those at once and just
think about a music for long the doc is
supposed to be completely raw and
unfiltered material the even Garth
learned a few things from his ex-wife's
appearance telling us weekly I was gone
so much on the road during our marriage
there were things I guess she was trying
to tell me but I didn't hear until it's
biography it's rare you get to hear the
other side I just saw her and I think a
hug her harder than I ever have
now that I know things that either I
didn't hear or that she didn't say until
now
Garth married sandy back in 1986 and
they share three daughters together in
2000 they divorced and five years later
Garth married now wife the fellow
country star Trisha Yearwood now Garth
admits he and Tricia met while he was
still married to Sandy and he recalls
the instant connection after meeting for
the first time revealing I've been
married for 13 months when it matter
when someone said what do you think when
I met her I said I felt like I just met
my wife now what did that person say
back to them after he said back cook now
Garth and Trisha didn't become
romantically involved until years later
these happy things unfolded the way that
they did
admitting if we got married then either
the career wouldn't have been what it
was in the 90s or a marriage wouldn't
have lasted I had to believe that things
happen when they happen I feel very
lucky right now where I'm at I mean if I
did have regrets I wouldn't change
anything
you're changing where I'm at right now
so it sounds like there's a lot more to
learn with the highs and lows of Garth's
personal and professional life and looks
like he's discovered a lot too what do
you think Bogaerts comments about his
ex-wife and make sure blessed know what
you think of Garth Brooks the wrote Aman
after the two-part premiere two nights